the final day of our workshop on ai and
humanity
my pleasure to be
sharing this session um
unusually this morning we have just two
papers not three is to be the customer
across the workshop
first up we're going to hear from serena
and
then we'll take questions to both
speakers
and from the audience and so
welcome to the workshop
thank you yeah so i'm serena i'm a
fourth year phd student here at berkeley
and i
am today going to be talking about our
work on reimagining the machine learning
life cycle in education
and this is joint work with other folks
at berkeley from both the cs side and
from the education graduate school of
education uh so that's lydia liu and
myself and ready at abe and talani
britain from the uc berkeley gse
so machine learning is being used in a
lot of ways in education today and more
and more and more so as you know the
pandemic happened and all that and maybe
one way that we typically think about is
massive open online courses or moocs
but machine learning is also being used
in higher education and k-12
for example machine learning gets used
to predict student dropout risk and the
goal here is to
maybe prevent students from dropping out
or you know anticipate that and
intervene earlier
it gets used in automatic automated
grading and essay scoring so in the gre
it's being used and different
standardized tests um at the k12 level
um
it's being used in admissions and it
actually is being used in
in like real admission systems today um
a couple an example of which i'm going
to talk a bit more about
next
um it gets used to predict test question
difficulty in the design of standardized
testing so again kind of the testing
space
um and it gets used in intelligent
tutoring systems so maybe more of what
we would typically think of
uh and you know as chat bots for
advising systems that like
the ways in which it's being used are
like
uh increasing there's more and more of
them as you go
so i'm going to talk more about the
admissions problem and the way that uh
machine learning is being used there and
this is i think a lot of us can
empathize with this being a very
difficult problem um i know personally i
was i have reviewed uh graduate school
applications at berkeley and it really
is like a um
a
emotionally and like energy taxing
process where you know you're i had like
a pile of 200 applications that i really
wanted to do a good job with reading and
like these are you know there's whole
like personal statements and letters and
stuff and you uh
anyway so
i really i could empathize with um
ut austin back in 2013 when they found
that the number of applicants to their
cs graduate program was increasing
beyond the capacity that they had
in terms of their admissions committee
and the resources that they had to
review these applications
so at the time in 2013 they had this
idea to automate part of the process
and they came up with this system called
the graduate admissions evaluator or
grade
and what grade would do is it would take
your admissions packet so like your
your personal statement your transcripts
gpa like resume information letters
recommendation gre scores
and it would use that to try to predict
the probability that you a student would
be admitted by the admissions committee
and the data for that was in the form of
past admissions outcomes and decisions
from 2009 to 2012.
and according to they published a paper
in 2014 uh discussed like talking about
their their system and according to that
paper grade makes the review process
more efficient for two reasons and the
first it is it reduced the total number
of full application reviews the
committee must perform so the way that
it worked was basically like the machine
learning model would predict us like a
probability of admission between zero
and one and if that probability was
really low like predicting a likely
reject then the they would recommend
that the application just goes for like
a quick review
um if it predicted something borderline
then uh the application would go through
the full review process of like you know
what we currently have set up and
at least separately and
what we think of as this full like you
have your
yeah uh including faculty and all that
and then if the score was really high
like predicting high likelihood of
acceptance it would also be recommended
for a quick review but in practice even
the the ones that were likely accepted
would also go through the full review
process
so the second reason that grade was
supposed to make the review process more
efficient was but that by assigning a
ranking to the applications it was
supposed to make it easier to review an
individual applicant's file so um for
for instance if you have say myself with
like a huge pile of applications um
trying to go through them what the grade
would do is it would like order them in
uh it would like rank them and then
order them so that like the reviewer
would read them in order of
its its ranking
and
so the reviewer would not only see the
application itself but they would also
see the
grade ranking
and it did do what they claimed it did
right so grade managed to reduce the
number of full reviews required per
applicant by 71
and also cut the total time spent
reviewing files by at least 74
so it achieved their efficiency goals
um but
yeah well maybe what they didn't
anticipate is the fallout after that so
this um
system ran quietly for from 2013 to 2020
when and by quietly i mean it wasn't
like publicized on their website or
anything it's just they did technically
have this paper out so the information
was out there but i don't think that it
wasn't like easy for
um
prospective applicants to find or
anything like that
um but in 2020 they were going around
like giving some talks about this um
system
and in one of these talks there was a
graduate student who
like kind of posted something on twitter
and then it kind of became really public
knowledge knowledge that they were doing
this
and this led to a whole kind of
controversy and a lot of discussion
around this system that summarized
pretty well in this article from inside
higher ed so i'll point you to there if
you want to read more about it
um but i'm just going to point out two
points from this like
controversy and from um people's
reactions to kind of knowing that this
uh system was out there and the first
reaction was
a quote from this article which is that
at ut nearly 80 of undergraduates in
computer science in 2017 were men
so this is kind of pointing to an
ongoing um representation and diversity
issue in the computer science
departments and i know they're talking
about undergraduates here but that's
what feeds into the graduate schools and
so what they're finding is that like
with grade being out for almost a decade
it wasn't helping this
issue and possibly you know they were
like oh is it possibly making it worse
or perpetuating some of the stereotypes
that exist
or biases that exist um and
the second quote that i'm gonna pull
from this is that uh is a quote from
somebody who was at
that one of the talks at the university
of maryland who said i'm kind of shocked
you did this experiment on your students
you seem to have built a model that
builds in whatever bias your committee
had in 2013 and you've been using it
ever since
um
okay so in reaction to all this
criticism uh in 2020 uh ut posted this
uh tweet saying that they are pulling
the algorithm they're no longer going to
use it and i'm also going to point out
two different parts of this tweet
the first is that
is kind of one of the re is the reason
they point out for um wanting to pull
the algorithm where they say they're
deeply committed to addressing a lack of
diversity in the field
and this
uh
lack of diversity thing kind of
refers to a social good objective which
wasn't included in the initial like
the previous goal that we discussed or
that the paper discussed i'm just trying
to make the process more efficient
but
so what they point out is that when they
say that they're aware of the potential
to encode bias into machine learning
based systems
that refers to a way that the machine
learning system is falling short of
achieving some broader goals that they
had right
so this when we're talking about okay
well what are the ways that machine
learning model the machine learning
system falls short
this is kind of what
pretty close to the question that we're
trying to answer here which is what are
ways in which machine learning models
and the way that we build and structure
them and uh the practices around them
how do they actually
either fall short or try to achieve the
different like actual broader social
goals that we have with these systems
so to pursue this study we took this
paper we took grade and we um
highlight we kind of annotated it we
tried to pull out like what were the key
and core parts of the system and how did
they build it and we
you know we can't answer that ourselves
as just computer scientists so we
actually took this over to our
colleagues at the graduate school of
education um and at graduate schools of
education around the united states and
we asked we did a series of interviews
asking them uh basically what do you
think of these different parts of the
way that the system was built and how
well do you think that it will actually
achieve
real goals in education that you see
today
so some of the kinds of things that we
highlighted were things like what was
the stated goal in the paper
well they say that its purpose is to
inform the admissions committee and make
the process of reviewing files more
efficient okay so that's one thing that
they say they want to achieve and the
second is like well how did they say
they were achieving the goal what was
the like building of the system
and so they in this grade paper was as a
machine learning problem grade frames
graduate admissions as probabilistic
binary classification
um and then another thing that we would
pull out is well what were they using to
evaluate the system how are they
measuring success and um in the grade
paper they say the system is best
understood by its precision recall
characteristics so things like that
um
this is just a small sampling and we
didn't we did that not just for grade
but as i mentioned earlier um we like
machine learning is used throughout many
different areas in education and we
actually did this for 20 papers total
uh
surveyed from a
bro like pulled from a survey on ai for
social good including things like
progressive prediction of student
performance in college programs
um formative essay feedback using
predictive scoring models identifying
at-risk students in massive open online
courses and
you know lots of
yeah um
a total of 20 different papers and the
question that we asked and that we
focused our interviews on was are the
stated or implied social good objectives
of these machine learning for education
research papers aligned with the machine
learning tasks objectives and data sets
that are outlined in the papers and why
or why not
so
okay yeah i think how am i out okay
great um
okay so to get into the um the i mean
i'd like to give a kind of brief
overview of the results that we found
and then we'll also be paper forthcoming
that um you know we'll have all the
details so to get into like kind of a
structure of the results i'm first going
to outline this supervised machine
learning paradigm where
you start with some data set which
includes some input features and a
prediction target from there
you know you train a machine learning
model function and from that model
function there that generates a set of
predictions so in the great example
those predictions would be like the
predictive probabilities of admission
and i'm going to refer to this as the ml
problem box which is where a lot of the
like research in fate and fairness
accountability and transparency like
where a lot of that focuses
um and indeed within this box there's
been a lot of important work looking at
how like factors here will contribute to
like social good issues right one
example is um address there's been a lot
of work addressing bias in the data
itself
and there's been a lot of work
addressing bias in the predictions
themselves like what do the outcomes
look like
um but what we actually found was that
through a lot of our interviews um a lot
of the points and really the key points
that our
experts were bringing up
couldn't quite fit so neatly into this
box
for example um one participant said i'm
not sure of the specific approach of
giving a ranking to
uh to the applications
another participant said that well when
they read the when we went through the
paper together they found they like
pulled out this point that um actually
the grade system wasn't they it wasn't
actually using the statement of purpose
it decided that that wasn't predictive
so this participant says well
if if it like doesn't matter what the
student says in their statement of
purpose because grade just like threw
that out and it doesn't predict anything
then like what does that really mean
about the admission system right like
what we're asking students to do
and then this participant also says that
actually if you ask a student do you
want your application that they spend a
lot of time on to just go through an
algorithm i think they would say no so
this
uh this is kind of pointing out that
maybe what the student wants or the
student um
yeah maybe how the student is thinking
about this process and what their goals
are differ from what the institution
thinks
so
finding that like many of these issues
were actually not so neatly in this box
we had to reimagine the machine learning
life cycle
and the way that we uh reimagined it was
it was this way which is kind of i guess
it's kind of a straightforward thing for
a lot of like folks in the sts community
but if you have
we the machine learning problem box is
actually just a small part of the real
full life cycle that a machine learning
model goes through and the first is
beginning in this life cycle is some
practitioners and researchers who have
some education goals in mind so in the
grades example they needed say the
process to be efficient and maybe they
also decided later that they had these
kind of diversity
goals
and from those goals a machine learning
pro that's what like formulates this
machine learning problem or from there
one can formulate you know the data sets
you choose what predictions you want to
make um
but the predictions at the end of the
story because those also need to be
translated into an intervention which
actually is the final thing that impacts
the education stakeholders so in the
great example though that means that
like the predictions actually had to get
passed to the admissions officers who
made the final decisions
and so in expanding this life cycle we
found that there's actually we
categorized
um
some of the the criticisms and the the
like recommendations from our interviews
into two different translation gaps
uh oh yeah and of course there's a
validation and feedback cycle here and
the first translation gap is this
problem of translating the education
goals into
this machine learning problem box via
problem formulation
and the second translation gap that we
highlight in the paper is
translating those predictions to
interventions like what
what are some key points there
and i think i have i'm going to use the
last couple of minutes to talk a little
bit give a bit of a preview of some of
the findings in each of those areas
so first
when translating education goals via
problem formulation there's like we
found there are a couple of interesting
findings which i do want to highlight
here
and the first is that education goals um
were often conflated with
short-term metrics that were being used
in the problem formulation process
so what do i mean by that well the
machine learning paper for education
papers would focus on a single
quantitative metric so for example they
want to improve on-time graduation rates
but actual education goals were a lot
broader and a lot more long term
um for instance one participant said oh
we don't want to just limit ourselves to
graduation rates we want to look at
other things like retention rates but
retention rate is kind of a longer term
thing you need to do a longer study to
see
to see that another example is well
graduating with satisfaction was
something they were interested in but
this is also a more qualitative concept
that's not as easily measurable as just
your rate of grad the graduation rates
and so in general there was a bias
towards shorter term outcomes because
that's kind of what's convenient to
measure but there wasn't really like a
logical map drawn out of why do we care
or how does this outcome actually map
onto this goal that we have
adding on to this issue is that there's
also multiple stakeholders in these uh
systems there's not just like one single
goal even if we could measure it
um
even the education so first the
education institutions themselves could
have competing goals
um and these tensions are not
necessarily acknowledged in the the
papers for instance
with grade they had an efficiency goal
um and they also you know this
efficiency also has to do with like
maybe financial goals for the university
and they would also have equity and
access goals which uh may come from some
kind of mandate if they're a public
institution
but the individual student goals
actually often differ okay from
institution level goals
um
right so
uh i think i'm out of time now but we
also had some like there's there's quite
a bit more also on like this issue of
like translating these predictions to
interventions so um please reach out and
i will send over the paper and it's
currently under review so
um thank you
[Applause]
sure